it's freezing cold in the classroom but
these first graders are full of
enthusiasm they eagerly practice
spelling to be able to go to school is
the most important thing for them
otherwise their time would be spent on
the streets or in a refugee camp
sonamoo rond is in charge of them she's
a businesswoman from northern Syria who
also fled the conflict there
single-handedly she has established
three schools for almost 1,000 kids in
war times you sometimes need to do
unusual things and take a stand when I
came to Turkey I didn't know where she'd
sent my two children to school that's
how it is for many refugee families I
help people by establishing our own
school there are always setbacks but I
don't want to give up on this project
the school is called torches of freedom
it's a self-help project located 200
kilometers from the Syrian border
refugee teachers teach refugee children
it's financed by private donations
currently there are over a million
Syrian refugees living in Turkey they
are tolerated by the Turkish state but
the general rules regarding compulsory
education do not apply to them I went to
a Turkish school but I didn't understand
anything there in the geography lesson
the tenth graders are studying the map
of their home country but it's not just
about learning facts learning how to
interact with one another peacefully and
respectfully is also part of the
curriculum religious education plays
just a minor role when fifteen-year-old
Fatih leave school the next children are
already waiting to come in even with a
shift system the high demand can't be
met UNICEF says that of the 3 million
Syrian child refugees half have been
from education we're lucky in this city
most of the Syrian children of our age
need to work in workshops or factories
and can't go to school like us school
fatigue helps out in his family's shop
his father once owned two factories in
the Syrian city of Aleppo before he had
to flee because he had joined the
opposition they didn't want to stay in
the reception camp this small grocery
store keeps the family afloat because
the Turkish state allows refugees to
work I depend entirely on Syrian
customers only Syrian shop here Turkish
people come very rarely we Syrians stick
together and that helps but the son
doesn't see a future for himself in
Turkey Hadassah if I do well enough in
school I want to go to university in
another country more and more refugees
are establishing themselves in cities
the Turkish neighbors of missouri's shop
are not enthusiastic about it they're
worried about crime and competition with
jobs when they're in the camps under the
care of the state everything's fine but
when they're here in the city problems
arise the camp's would be better for
them too this boy comes from Syria but
he doesn't go to school
he runs deliveries for a kebab
restaurant how much do you earn for that
20 lira that's about 7 euros a week
Kahraman mara's has a population of
around a million 20,000 of which are
Syrians they've built new lives
opening shops and restaurants last
summer saw the first riots here Syrian
shops and cars were vandalized the
tensions are rising nationalist
politicians want a ban Arabic writing in
public
the Syrians feel unwanted
even on the school's playground wold you
can see anti-syrian graffiti because of
this many refugees want to move on with
their children to Europe or the USA even
the school director Sanibel Morandi
ideally wanted to go to Europe with her
husband but she decided to stay for the
sake of the school children we need to
stand together and establish ourselves
in Turkey of a long period of time I no
longer have any hope that we can return
home soon
without schools there's no future for
Syria Morandi says one day these
children will need to rebuild their
country which has been destroyed by war